être aux petits soins comme chaque jour
à plaisir l'épidémie de rim donc ne
money n'est pas d'actualité
les cavaliers n'ont pas connu de
concours juste avant l'épidémie
mais le personnel et les cavaliers sont
attentifs déjà qu'on avait des mesures
sanitaires mises en place lyoko vide
donc de déplacement de port de masques
et puis avec le couvre-feu on a déjà un
flux de personnes limitées au club il
faut rester vigilant de toute manière on
n'est à l'abri de rien mais voilà on
reste prudent dans le sens où moi ma
fenêtre elle est vaccinée non ça
m'inquiète pas trop après c'est plus
pour c'est possible qu'ils aient
certains chevaux de propriétaires qui
soient pas vaccinés lentilles ferait les
écuries de plaisir accueille plus de 80
chevaux des montures pour le sport et le
loisir 30 propriétaires leur font
confiance et le manque de compétition
depuis quasiment un an qui se fait
sentir
on a des shows en ce qu'on appelle -
valorisation donc on doit céder
propriétaire qui me confient des shows
pour les valoriser ça serait évidemment
ça se fait en compétition et là on s'est
arrêté les shows et valorise pas donc
ils prennent moins de valeur ça n'arrête
pas mais ça même une petite pause dans
le commerce et nous le commerce c'est
une source importante pour pouvoir
survivre
la rhinopneumonie a débuté à la fin du
mois de janvier en espagne 70 chevaux
ont été contaminées une dizaine on est
décédé la fédération française
d'équitation a prolongé le lundi 15 mars
la suspension des compétitions jusqu'au
11 avril